能理解吗？
还是有点费解。
不要紧。
记得我们的故事吗？
记得我们的故事吗？一个想要殉职的警察。
我们把它填进去好不好？
我们现场把一个想要殉职的警察填成10个序列。当时那个故事是有八要素的。
我们现在把它变成实序列。
一起来完成，好吧，它是在这一排是吧？
为了帮助大家更好的理解10个序列，我们用我们之前的一个想要殉职的警察那个例子。
来一起往里填一下，大家懂一懂这10个序列，我们光说哎呀这个开场开场之后就要切入，切入之后要激励，激励之后要进展，说的大家好像没有地方下手。
对不对？
而且你说切入那啥脏气，哎呀，天哪，那别切了，就容易崩溃。我们来往里写一写，你就不觉得崩溃了。
咱们之前写了8要素。
呃，还是有用的呃，很有用，它是我们的指导思想，好吧。
他在这里。
你的身份。
然后那个那个欲望。
动作。
这个。
问题。
主力。
结果。
然后一个正价值，一个负价值。
好吧。
十0个序列。
咱们那个故事是什么故事来着？
一个想要殉职的警察。
我们以课代表那个。
最后改出来的那个例子啊。
就课表那个例子，他他为什么想要殉职？
一个警察为什么想要殉职？
为了钱。
为了那叫什么抚恤金呢，你牺牲了，那肯定有钱买。然后他为什么要那个钱呢？他想留给老婆女儿。
留给妻女老小。
然后呢。
动了想因公殉职的这个念头。
这是当时那个故事。
我们说。
我当时说过。
你结局如果打在。
他成为了一个很棒的警察。
他通过这件事情。
认识到自己。
要做一个好警察。
以人物弧线来讲。
起点。
他应该是一个烂警察。
所以。
开场事件先够完成一件事儿，他是个烂警察。
他是个烂警察。
不负责任的警察。
你先把这一件事完成就可以了。
啊，有些同学会有个疑问啊，说咱们从梗概到大纲讲到现在，就老师好像教的故事里面只有一个角色。
有没有发现这个问题，只有一个人是吧？我跟你说，这就对了。
一直到写。
厂之前。
你所有的故事只有一个人。
只有一个角色，只有一个视角。
就是主角是你的，就是他这个主角，一个想要殉职的警察是个主角。
主角。
就这一个。
配角呢在哪？配角什么时候写？配角不是你创造出来的，配角是事儿创造出来的。
你今天主角想要处理去处理一个劫持人质的案件，那么那个劫匪那个人质就是两个配角。
配角从事儿上来。
不用现在去设计。
还有的人说，那主角也有好几个呀。这个你如果问我这个问题的话，就说明前面你课没有认真听。
主角有好几个的那那个也是从他拆出来的。
你写着写着发现一个人不够用。
我这个一个想要殉职的警察这个。
他想死。
不够用啊，那你就给咱设计一个搭档。
而且这个主角这个角色你本来设定他是想要殉职的警察。
那么你如果拆分出来一个搭档，这个搭档就是一个非常想要活下去的警察，是拆出来的。好吧，然后你这个警察是个非常英勇的。
那你有可能拆出来一个笨手笨脚。
就是这么一个意思。
好吗？所以主角。
只有一个，现在不用去考虑那些问题。
来这个警察开场这场戏。
是一个烂警察。
我们说符合一个烂警察。
比如说啊。
看到坏人行凶。
他作为一个警察都不制止。
烂到家了吧。
有坏人在那使坏，在那违法犯罪，你做一个普通人都有可能要见义勇为吧。
你作为一个警察都不管。
那足够烂了。
对不对？
我们可以设计这么一场戏。
一个警察就是这个主角。我上次跟大家说过，我说上来的话，其实把它设成一个协警啊，我们的空间更大。
我们的空间更大，一是审查问题。一个警察，你上来太烂的话，审查是肯定过不了的。
我们先给他设置一个协警，临时工都是顶班的，设置一个斜警，然后。
嗯，而且协警赚钱少。
主要是钱少，你后面你那个他对金钱的那个渴望才协警的话，起点更低。我们说第一场戏可以是一个协警。比如说啊。
在一个夜市儿。
摊儿上。
咱俩喝酒。
一个人。
一个人喝酒，首先证明。
这件事儿就挺惨了，混的又不太好，一个人搁那喝酒。
然后呢，这时候。
夜市摊上嘛鱼龙混杂，隔壁一桌有小流氓，比如说调戏女服务员。
欺负人吧。
不一定是女服务员，就欺负比如说这个开夜摊的这这一对很老实巴交的夫妻，弱势群体。
这点欺负人。
他是听见了的，看见了的。
他不管。
那继续喝他的酒。当然你可以设计他有烦心事儿啊。
对吧比如说跟他。
一直打他那个前妻的电话，打不通啊，然后对方那个那个小流氓在那里闹事儿，闹得越来越大。
动手了。
然后旁边有人报警了，报警了以后，那调度台肯定要。
在公共频道呼叫一下谁在附近。
这时候他桌上放着那他的对讲机，警用对讲机。
就滋啦滋啦开始。
呃，这个啥啥路啥啥路有个夜摊发生有有人斗殴，谁在附近请迅速前往处理。那这整个摊上的人肯定都都看他呀。
他还不管。
对讲机一关接着喝酒。
放任坏然行凶。
足够烂了吧。
发生在他们面前，对讲机还呼他。
他都没管一个烂警察，同时还交代了。
混的不咋地，一个人喝酒，而且还是夜摊。
对吧。
同时交代了他是个协警，不是个警察，旁边可能有人。
要说呀，说你你赶紧管管呀，你不是警察吗？那我是协警。
还能透露出他。
对生活不满意，对自己协警身份也不满。
这些事情全部交代一下，然后这个画面呢也挺荒诞的。
他在接警对面那打架，对讲机就在这儿，对方听了，开始还停下来了，觉得哇，警察原来就在这儿，发现了不管接着打，也能引起观众的兴趣，比较荒诞的一个开场。
那这就是一个开场戏。
你不就有了写了吗？
可以描述这东西很多。
把这个信息全部。
交代出来了。
混的不好。
四十郎当岁，协警没钱不负责任。
对吧全部交代了。
还有他的苦恼，就是离婚了，老婆和女儿都不搭理他。
甚至呃就是。
老婆现在可能找男朋友了。
不搭理他。
对吧女儿马上要叫别人叫爸爸。
对吧？
他说不定那个打那个电话，就是想问你们的结婚到底在哪办，敢不敢告诉我地址，人家不告诉他，怕他去闹事儿。
我就这么个事儿。
开场戏完成了。
10分之1有了，你把这场戏描述一下，咱们10分之1有了。
夜市摊上还是个动作戏吧。
有环境，有动作，有对白。
开上戏完成了。
我们说切肉洗。
切入系，我说是什么来着？
继续。
延续他的。
各种信息那些设定，然后为激励事件做一做准备。激励事件其实我们可以想起来了，激励事件就是我们基本上心里有谱的啊，激励事件其实就是它萌生。
诈骗点钱的这个。
这发端嘛，我们说激励事件是核心问题的发端嘛，核心问题的发端就是我要搞笔钱。
通过以身殉之搞笔钱。
那么切入这里铺垫，那我们就可以加强第一场的人物设定呀。
第一第一场他那个最大的痛苦来自于哪？
第而。
妻女嘛？
找他们去。
这场接下来的第二场戏来，第一场戏是醉酒。
街边那场醉酒第二场戏就耍酒疯不就完了吗？
或者第二天早晨直接。
第一场如果是个夜绩的话。
第二天早晨。
对吧。
还是穿的头天晚上的衣服。
恕罪脏了吧唧，咣咣咣去敲人家。
前七家的门。
肯定是被拒之门外，肯定是被数落一段，肯定是连女儿都不搭理他。
但是如果仅仅表达这些是不太够的。因为这些第一场已经表达过了，他老婆女儿不搭理他。
我们想办法。
想办法什么呢？让他更上火，更生气，更窝囊。
不就想这样的办法吗。
我在直播的时候给大家说过啊。
我说作为一个中年男人啊，虽然我没有到，但是我能共情到中年男人。
就是说作为一个中年男人。
没有钱，当然会让你沮丧。
嗯，没有社会地位，当然也会让你抬不起头来。
但是啊我猜啊我没有女儿啊，我猜如果我是这个协警。
我最让我失去。
男人雄风男性尊严的事情是什么？就是我眼看我如花似玉的十八九岁的女儿，豆蔻年华的女儿被小流氓搞。
跟小流氓去，比如说就很明显的你能感知到他们俩。
呃，睡了。
是最让我失去男人尊严的事情。
在这里我们就可以。
在这一段就用上。
他去找他。
前妻和女儿，这俩人肯定是不搭理他的，第一场戏已经透露了，那第二场戏来。
就让他受打击呗。
但是那样写的话就有点太惯性了。
我们这么写好不好？你看啊。
他不是离婚了吗？
那他老婆找的男朋友。
比他壮比车比他好，他他协警，他可以没有车。
其实也是让他受打击的。
这个男人不用多好，这个男人只要你看到你，你就挺臊眉大眼的对吧？所以这个男人必须也在。
我们这么设计一下，你看能不能气死他啊。
就是这个男人。
那肯定也是个中年大叔嘛，四十来岁。
这个男人有个儿子。
这个男人父子俩。
住进了。
他之前的家。
跟他的妻女。
住在一块儿。
这个男的明很明显是他老婆的前妻的男朋友嘛。然后呢，他又看这个小子又跟自己的女儿。
也不清不楚的。
他可以看到点啥。
我觉得这件事能活活气死他。
就对方父子两个把他家所有的女人都搞了。
能活活气死。
而且对方明显是比如说小流儿稀气。
无业游民。
没有工作，就蹭他家房子。
对吧。
但是呢他老婆孩子觉得。
挺好呀，人家至少。
能陪伴我们，你你算干嘛地？
这能让他愈发的。
失去男人威严。
而且也是具有一定戏剧冲突的。
具有一定看点。
就对方父子二人。
就在他家能气死，所以第二场也搞定。
他去找青女。
对吧办点什么事儿或者送点赡养费。
结果发现赡养费全部给。
那对父子买买哈尔滨的，买啤酒的。
那是不是能祸坏其子？
然后呢，我们说激励世界是钱，所以在这个切入世界里面，我们得把钱搞出来了啊。
我们得把钱搞出来了啊。
钱必须在这里提出来了啊。
我们第一场已经交代了，他其实是挺穷的，但没有。
狠狠的交代。所以在切入这里啊，钱这件事情要能印出来了，等于是他去找这个母女两人啊，可以是他女儿。比如说他。
感情生活上肯定是拦不住他女儿的。
但是呢跟女儿比如说聊几句，女儿要去读一个什么？
音乐学院。
啊。
艺术学那种学费的又忒贵啊，花钱不牢骚，问他要。
没有。
等于是你在威严上，在生活上颜面扫地。
然后呢，但是呢人家给了你一个机会，就是你如果能把这钱掏了，其实是能挽回分数的。
结果你又掏不上，你又掏不上。然后女儿说行了吧，我知道他，那我问问我李叔。
气人不气人，你说气人不气人，活活气死，对吧？所以说钱这个事儿在切入这里啊。
在这个这个铺垫这里，就是他去前妻家把这个钱的事儿拎出来，受一再受一个。
压垮骆驼的最后一个稻草刺激来激励事件激励事件就很明确了啊。
我们说他。
最终是想要以身殉职嘛。
那么激励事件一定是。
让他灵光一闪。
那就是回到警局。
回到警局上班回到警局上班，可以再再次强调一下他在警局的身份地位。
这是一个中中老年的协景嘛。
再次强调一下他在警局的身份地位。我们说每场戏啊都得带着点前面的延续，不要那么自私说我这场戏就完成激励就行了。啊，回来警局再交代一下。
然后比如说回到警局干什么啊？
让他灵光一闪，灵光一闪，肯定是哎我要以身殉之，肯定是有例子呀。
比如说捐款。
捐款呀。
对吧。
捐款一人100块。
捐款那们体制内单位不都经常规定嘛？一人100块也不多捐，也不少捐一人100块。然后他呢本来钱就挤。
还要再捐100块，心里还骂骂咧咧的说捐给谁呀，说谁谁谁他我也不认识，他说对没有人认识，是隔壁县的。
对吧不是这个县的，隔壁一个县，但咱都属于一个地级市，隔壁一个县的某个警察。
壮烈了。
然后呢。
呃这个这个。
给他捐款，然后他还就他在骂骂咧咧当中把这些信息传达到问那捐什么呀，他任务牺牲了，那没有抚恤金吗？他说抚恤金有150万。但是呢呃那个一条人命的，留着老婆孩子妻儿老小的这个系统内。
咱们全省号召。
呃，广大这个同行。
这个同袍战这个战友大家自愿捐款，然后他说那我他妈也不认识他，我不是自愿的，还骂骂咧咧爹。
钱捐上了对吧？捐上了之后更发觉囊中羞涩更生气。但是。
萌发了。
哎呀。
我也可以。
走这条路。
这个念头。
我们说。
这有的一叫核心问题的发端嘛，萌发的。
对吧你可以一个眼神，观众就懂了。因为到这里啊。
铺垫了他那么怂，铺垫了，他那么没钱，然后铺垫了这个事情。然后他一抬头，脑子一转，观众就懂了，他要往那琢磨了。
好吧，第三件事儿又有了吧，在警局里。
对吧在警局里，当然了，你可以分加强他。比如说他回警局先被什么领导骂一顿呐，对吧？被人那个骂他之前。
明明在那个为什么关对讲机之类的。
但是核心的问题在这儿只要把这个事儿给办了。
就是一件事情刺激到他，让他觉得他也可以以身训之，最好就是得有个样子嘛，这样让观众也懂呀。
我觉得捐款挺好的。
参加追悼会也是个思路，但是那就有点顺拐，就回去之后有个同事牺牲了，然后参加追悼会，然后看着别人哇，真真英勇，真光荣，然后大家还给他钱，这个有点顺拐，最好是捐款。
对吧还有点意思。
好，你看前三件事情。
完成了。
进展。
我们说进南是什么？
一次动作。
一次无效的尝试嘛，那就好办了。那就好办了。比如说我们说就挟持人质吧，看到有人挟持人质，拿着个炸弹，比如说不用挟持人质，有人身上装了个炸弹，扬言要炸掉那个那个那个某个银行的营业厅，在那身上绑着炸弹，那所有人都围着不敢上。
对吧呃呃。
叫谈判专家报告那个地方上的特警队，然后狙击手安排就位拆弹专家呃，那个stand by所有都是那个那个这个套路。
然后那个局长也来了，拿个大喇叭，隔着安全距离，躲在车后面哇叽里呱啦在那对对方喊话。
觉得机会来了。
他作为一个协警，本来在那维持秩序，哎大家往后站往后站维持秩序，然后他觉得机会来了。
对吧小棍儿一扔，我上。
径直走向那个。
身上绑炸弹那个胸图。
然后上去还窜人家。
你要加油你要加油。
装了多少是吧？炸起来能炸多大范围，别炸不死啊，炸残了，让我遭罪，我可跟你玩命，最好是能一下炸死，我离你近点，你再引爆太远了，别给我炸个半残，我合不合算，我往你近一点，你再引爆，哎，等会儿等会儿我再近一点。哎，咱俩抱着，你爆吧。
结果给那歹徒吓蒙了，其他人也都看不懂。
听不着那说什么呀？
最后这个歹徒放弃抵抗，他计划失败，一次无效的尝试。
对吧你次无效的尝试。
但是这里可以做一个什么啊，无效的尝试以后。
升值了。
升值了呀。来。
这次无效尝试之后，那在转折这里。
升职加息怎么样？
升职加薪。
获得了一定的。
小成就。
可以吧。
不要加薪了，加薪这个成就太大了。
我们这样。
受到的表彰怎么样？
受到了表扬表彰。
获得了一定的荣誉，但是还没是没有解决钱的问题。
但是呢。
给予一定的甜头，为后面。
打一点伏笔，他最后要做一个好人嘛，在这里下一点点伏笔。进展这里啊这里有点单薄一件事情。
我们可以让他多尝试几次。
就是说那次处理爆炸案呢。
没有直接让他得到表扬和表扬。
我们让他多尝试几次，就是说他认准了这条路了。
反复尝试，我们说一次动作一这个无效尝试一次不够。
我们在这里啊多写几场写。
嗯。
最好是针对它原片区的。
原来片区。
那些他以前不敢动的。
呃，黑社会也好，刑满释放人员也好，那个地痞无赖也好，就以前他不敢动的，他作为协警不太敢动的。
全处理一下。
包括还可以处理一下啥。
那这副词。
不小流氓吗？
可以去找他们查。
等于是他他得到了一个认为他就是生命光环以后，他觉得命无所谓以后。
做好几次无效尝试。
都没死成。
那些平常看起来穷凶极恶的人。
在面对不要命的他的时候，全都怂了，因为没有人拿生命开玩笑。
等于做好多次无效无效尝试。
在最后一次处理一个大的爆炸案的时候。
得到了。
就面临真正的爆炸案的时候。
又处理掉了，我们把这个报价往后推一推啊。
然后获得了升值，获得了表彰。
我们把无效尝试这里多次。
然后这里。
再得到表彰。
这样的话更合理。
边捋边改边想啊。
然后这次表彰比如说啊。
表彰过后，短暂的甜蜜马上把它打下来。我这里其实往上走的啊，上扬有点太多了，马上把它打下来。
我在想怎么把它打下来。
最好就是这种时候啊把一个人打下来啊，把一个人就是一个人获得短暂胜利，把他打回原形，最好就是原罪，就是他以前的原罪。我们这里能想到的原罪啊，比如说啊就是他第一场戏不是放走一个小流氓吗？
第一场戏报警，人家在对讲机里反复呼叫他，他都无视。后面闹那个闹事的小流氓，那个小流氓在欺负。
百夜摊卖炒面的这对。
老实八交的夫妻嘛。
假设他在这里被表彰转正。
从协警变成真正的警察。
对吧当然这里被表彰转正之后，他肯定有一场戏。
带着新的警徽去又去找他老婆孩子。
可能人家已经。
彻底被他失望。
你明白这个意思吗？这里可以加一场那种戏，就说这里不不是说每一个只有一场戏啊。
你看这里他被表彰从协警收为警察之后，你完全可以加一场。
他觉得自己现在人模人样。
他又要去找他老婆女儿。